willing I have children I will not be
giving them this no matter how hard they
cry fall off the floor at the Ralphs I'm
not this is not happening in my
household
we're swapping some snacks today let's
start tasting round one round one I'll
go first okay
in Latino culture typically after you
eat you have a little cafe a little
coffee after you eat my mom would not
let me have coffee were you allowed to
have coffee no as a kid okay see I feel
like that's a universal thing but for us
my mom what do I see I'm gonna stay
short yes that was it you're gonna
remain short that was the that was the
rumor so I kind of feel like because I
would sneak a lot of coffee I feel like
I like stunted Myself by a little bit my
arms like are a little bit longer I
swear if you stand up like I had long
arms okay you'd like to blame that on
the coffee because I did sneak a lot of
coffee as Fair Theory oh my God
oh my God no you think it is aloe vera
juice
it tastes like green Jello it's surge
have you heard of it no I've never heard
of this it looks like something from
like the Toy Story Cinematic Universe it
was like this 90s soda pop okay soda pop
who says soda I guess you do apparently
I'm like really everyone's like wow
she's old so I heard it has like double
the caffeine which makes total sense
because whenever we would have it we
would just be kind of like all like
jittery like at PE and like you know we
couldn't even like focus in class is
there any more of this can I have it I
mean oh my gosh your own my very own
take me back take me back the notes of
next one
my mom didn't let me have
what is this this is so wasteful like
where's the crust she was like if you
want me to do that like I'll push the
sides down for you and still make you
eat the crust you know yeah oh my God
it's not that deep you know let me show
you what I brought today
Donuts I could not have Donuts name so
it's really close to a Krispy Kreme all
these kids are bringing Krispy Kremes
for their birthdays and what am I
bringing I'm bringing these Mexican
wedding cookies it's not my wedding it
was never my wedding that was what my
mom would make for me to bring to class
Cheers Cheers all right
oh my God this is like taking me back
can I have something I was gonna say can
I try yours let's swap on top of the
swap how about that all right mom look
at me oh this one is like key lime pie
Eat My Pie slay if I had children I
would not deny them the pleasure of a
donut or an uncrustable no of course it
was rough watching kids have that and
not me
let's do it
I'm traumatized you were
never into Rice Krispies the homemade
version one thousand yeah I agree like
having a homemade one versus the wrapped
one it's a game changer it is have you
had a Rice Krispie treats cereal girl
that was the best thing in the world to
me drop into a split come back up yes it
is so good that expression before what
um
what is happening okay what I mean I'm
gonna start using that that's the effect
of Rice Krispie treats cereal I like how
they had to give you a fork for that
okay so if yours doesn't need a utensil
maybe mine was okay okay I'm excited
oh
oh my God wait was this little with the
Penguin on it yes yes this must have
been your favorite thing ever I've never
had it done oh my God oh my God I still
haven't had it what is this right what
is that that's a brownie my mom would be
like do you not want to poop oh
is that too much but now I really want
to try it okay
what is it good
chicken nugget like I'm gonna tear up
that was nasty that wasn't bad the mac
and cheese right
um this is like Kraft macaroni and
cheese
but you know as a Mexican I'm very picky
on my corn because I like
a steam chili powder
cheese
that's not a chicken nugget I don't know
what I'm eating can I have that surge to
wash it down real quick this is terrible
like right search yellow five I'm like
willing I have children I will not be
giving them this no matter how hard they
cry fall off the floor at the Ralphs I'm
not this is not happening in my
household
stop
let's do it oh shots
oh my gosh White Rabbit creamy candy so
when you open it show us what you I
already I would go like this okay oh and
then there's paper do you eat the paper
you eat the paper I love eating paper it
like melts in your mouth I'm like Mom I
want candy she's like you want candy eat
my rabbit did you ever own a white
rabbit we did yeah I only heard of the
hard-hitting questions here it was kind
of very like claw
I've always wanted to have it but my mom
said they'd die within like two days so
I apparently they don't but that's just
what you told me another thing my mom
wouldn't let me have that's another a
rabbit can I um yes reveal let's see
what we have
another candy okay okay my mom's
favorite candy is Almond Joy I was not a
big candy person growing up think about
it you'd go to the store getting
Halloween candy all the candy is gone
except for this except for the Almond
Joy listen I was onto something I was
onto something did I just buy it at
first it's one of those things you kind
of let it sit in your mouth and it
softens over time it's kind of a thing
all the way commit commitment
let's let it sit
okay I mean as a kid does that look
appealing
I don't know why I treated it like that
just
the initial change is kind of like
pulling on what used to but I'm kind of
liking this note it just kind of tastes
like sweet and condensed milk that's
accurate I agree with you on that
[Music]
okay I know this is weird weird but I
need to talk about this most people
don't trust the government I don't trust
lettuce what about now as an adult I
don't I don't eat it I like Romaine but
I was just like is this for my white
rabbit or I don't know like what's
happening I'm confused yeah it's a gift
[Music]
what is that now this is traumatic okay
what is this it looks like rocks or
something that you put in like your
hamster's cage like for them look both
of these go perfectly in a hamster cage
where is our White Rabbit legit
bring out the bunny right now it's
called grape nuts but interestingly it
doesn't contain like grapes or nuts
grapes like raisins or nuts it's like
barley and wheat this is what's not
gonna let you poop for days no that's
what my mom thought would help right I
hope they're not giving this to you dry
that's going to be hard to take down
they look down they looked out for you
because I thought they were gonna do you
like how you did me with this roommate
I wasn't trying to do that to you it's
okay we'll get through it I'm like
genuinely afraid of eating this tastes
like the Earth you know I mean I love
lettuce I love like it I like vegetables
it's just I mean
I don't know why when you made that face
I made that face how was it
I think it's even more strange that they
were able to find this like who is still
eating this I was gonna ask for a spoon
but I was like nah pass it genuinely
feels like there's rocks in my mouth I
took a really big bite why because I'm
dumb I don't know I don't know why you
did that yeah and then maybe wash it
down with this girl no but anyway there
you go it's like wheat and barley I'm
gonna cry it's so nasty look at that
that's a hate crime any other show like
does for housewives like sometimes they
would like poison a husband
s legit let's please let's go to the
next one I can't do this anymore this is
the last final snap yes that our parents
would want to push on to us
nagariah
cracker nuts coated peanuts
roasted peanuts and like there's like
this crunchy shell on top but this was
my mom's way of like I wanted like
Cheeto pups or something fun she'd be
like go in the cupboard and get the
nagaraya but I would eat it I did like
the garlic flavor but I would just like
suck the outside and then I would throw
the rest of it out okay I feel like this
one isn't that bad come through come on
cucumbers this is my mom's favorite
snack it's something she's watching
reality TV she's eating this she's
watching Law and Order she's eating this
like this is her go-to snack another fun
fact about me is I don't like cucumber
it came through with the garlic it did
it's really good I would eat this get
another one and kind of like as you get
it like roll like roll it between your
fingers let me see your fingers what I'm
gonna say
listen this is the best part
that's the best part oh my God that is
amazing right I would just go through
and just say touch it from Flavor down
to like like all like the entire finger
that was really like a spiritual journey
for me wasn't it that was really good
anyway
it's my mom I feel like I should be
looking at you for the reaction because
I I like cucumbers this might have
changed my life I might like cucumbers
now
wait a lot as of today I'm going really
can we bring that Romaine back I think
we can try that why not
that's different there's E coli involved
oh my gosh oh my gosh okay sorry that
wasn't that bad mom I think you were
onto something here I might owe you an
apology well we had things that we never
thought we would get the chance to eat
maybe some were disappointing some
really want us over Mom you write about
Kid Cuisine you were kind of right about
the Cucumbers kid Cuisines were like I'm
there with you mom that that was
terrible thanks for looking out love you
Mom Mom you're the best
foreign
[Music]